oh a little different than basketball
press conference
a lot of media in here today
I guess I'm gonna start with y'all today
right now
um first off I was thank y'all for
covering me and um all the exposure that
you you gave me my family
um to get me home I really appreciated
that that coverage was was much needed I
would like to encourage all of you to be
at our first game as well and the whole
entire season covering not only the
Phoenix Mercury with the best fans in
the league but the whole entire league
as well you know from start to finish I
I expect to see the same coverage
because we have a great product and
you'll see it this this summer
um
start off with uh with the Mercury thank
you so much everybody with the Phoenix
Mercury organization all the hard work
long hours everything that y'all did to
uh
for me my wife my family getting me back
home being there supporting me letting
me know that I wasn't alone it means
everything to me
to everybody events price gym I mean
coach everybody the players uh I mean it
goes all the way down to the people that
keep this building running
you know it's a family with the Mercury
um I would also like to thank bring our
families home
that uh thank you so much for being here
and representing everybody here
it means it means the world to have you
here right now and everything that you
did also and that you're that you're
you're doing you're so strong I just
want to say thank you so much
um of course President Biden vice
president Harris
um
Governor Richardson uh I mean the list
goes on to to everybody that was a part
of this the WNBA
um
wnbpa Wasserman my agent who's here as
well a lot a lot of long hours
you of course my wife I mean come on now
like I couldn't have did it without her
a round of applause for my wife honestly
she had the hardest job honestly
um thank you so much babe for being
there for me I
oh yeah
you the one
uh you know we can just get into it uh
let us started taking some questions you
know so we just keep it moving along
like it's post game
hello
so good to see you you too
what resilience has been required for
you to be sitting up here today how have
you found the resilience personally
to be here with us
you know I'm no stranger to uh to Hard
Times so
you crying you made me cry
um
just digging deep honestly you know uh
you're going to be faced with
adversities
um throughout your life uh this was a
pretty big one
but I just kind of relied on my hard
work getting through it I know this
sounds so small but you know dying in
practice you know and just hard workouts
uh
you found a way to just grind it out
just put your head down and just keep
going just keep moving forward you know
you can never stand still and that was
my thing just never never be still never
get too focused on on the now and just
you know looking forward to you know
what's to come
hey uh BG Mac upman with ABC News I
think I Echo everyone and my colleagues
here we are so happy to see you here
thank you and I don't know if it was
timed with your availability today but
you may know that uh The Washington Post
the New York Times The Wall Street
Journal put out an ad demanding the
release of Evan gershkovich today right
um so
during your detention were you aware of
all of the efforts on your behalf of the
hashtag we are BG and what message would
you send to Evan and Paul Whelan today
um yes I was aware
um there was a little bit of a delay
um
getting news sometimes but I was aware
of the efforts and everything that was
going on I was able to see pictures
sometimes of different different things
the the we RBG so um just knowing that
and having that
just being aware of what was going on
when you know you don't know anything
you just you're there you're sitting
there you're you're like okay I know
people are are fighting for me or
bringing awareness
um to what's going on and uh those those
times where I was able to see what was
going on it definitely you know it it
made me a little bit more comfortable it
made me a little bit have hope which is
a really hard thing to have a really
dangerous thing to have because you know
when it doesn't work it's so crushing
and I would say to to everyone that is
wrongfully detained right now across the
world uh stay strong keep fighting don't
give up just keep waking up find a
little routine and and stick to that
routine and as best you can I know
that's what what helped me just finding
little things if it was just
whatever it was you know
um
just keep pushing because we're not
going to stop
we're not going to stop fighting we're
not going to stop bringing awareness to
everyone that's that's left behind right
now
I um it's it's Ewan McCarty with CBS
News
um first of all welcome back we're so
thrilled to have you here I was
wondering if you could explain a little
bit about what your ordeal did for your
mental and your physical health and what
your journey has been to get back to the
place where you are now where you're
about to about to embark on pre-season
um you know it was strenuous
um and coming back from basically you
know doing nothing uh not having any gym
or anything to be at um getting back
into it with heart it's still a process
um you know just the little things I
mean
doing a plank you know it was so simple
before and couldn't even stay up very
long you know and just a regular plank
when I first came back uh
because as an athlete you always want to
be where you left off and I left off
playoffs you know finals Chicago
um and I wanted to be that that player
when I started back and uh just
everybody telling me to give myself
Grace and uh take it's going to take
time but that's the hardest thing to do
to to a pro athlete because we always
want to be right back at our Tip-Top
shape
um so it's been a struggle but like I
said
it's it's liberating as well at the same
time just as a release just getting back
to my craft and then being here in
Phoenix you know with my coaches and my
teammates really supported me you know
at every step of away on the court
so it's been it's been pretty good
hi Brittany I am Stephanie Elam with CNN
and first of all I have to say there's a
great amount of lightness around you
which I think is kind of shocking
considering what you've been through
it's extraordinary
I'm curious if the desire to play
overseas in the off season is a need or
a want and if that is something that
needs to be addressed and if it is a
need what do you think needs to be
addressed about it
uh well I can say for me I'm never going
overseas to play again unless I'm
representing my country at the Olympics
you know if I make that team that'll be
the only time I would I would leave the
U.S soil and that's just to represent
the USA
um
I'll say this you know the whole reason
a lot of us go over you know is the pay
Gap
um you know a lot of us go over there to
to make an income to support our
families
Explorer are to support ourselves
[Music]
so I don't not any player that wants to
go overseas and you know make a little
bit extra money I'm hoping that our
league continues to grow and with as
many people in here right now covering
this I hope you continue like I said to
cover our league bring exposure to us I
hope a lot of these companies start to
invest in our craft because as you'll
see this season if you haven't watched
before we have a really good craft in
ourselves in the WNBA and it's a shame
that we have to leave our families for
holidays I mean you're missing
everything being away but at the same
time as much as I would love to you know
pay my light bill for the Love of the
Game
I can't you know
um
so I think that's that's probably one of
the biggest reasons people are still
going overseas
[Music]
um
and that's why I was there you know so
hopefully that changes though
BG Lena Washington 12 News welcome back
so good to see you we've seen you out
around town at the MLK Day March the WM
Phoenix Open the recently a Sons game
what did that feel like for you and how
did just walking around town change from
maybe two years ago
uh walking around town it's a little bit
a little bit different a little bit
different now but um it felt good just
being back just being on U.S soil
especially being back here in the valley
made this my home and um
it was really warming I had a nothing
but love you know being out and about
and just trying to get back to just
being normal you know just being able to
walk out the door
um and and go see and do things uh so
it's been amazing all the things that I
really couldn't do either because I was
overseas plans so I got to do a couple
of those things uh here recently which
which was really nice actually
hi Brittany Nick seletti from abc15 here
in Phoenix and I just want to welcome
you back to the valley I think I speak
for everyone who was just thrilled to
see you back here where you belong you
mentioned something I found very
interesting just a few moments ago you
had said that hope is a dangerous thing
to have I was wondering if you could
dive deeper into that for us and also
explain throughout this whole process if
you ever had a moment where you lost
hope and how did you get that hope back
uh
I'll say I'll say this
um when I did lose my hope looking at
photos of my family that that brought my
hope back
um just being able to see their faces
um that did it for me you know and a
moment where you kind of want to give up
you you know you look at the photos and
it kind of brings you back you know you
know what you're waiting on you're
waiting to be back with your family you
know with your loved ones and uh in a
safe place so
um I'll go that far and say that but the
rest you know you have to have to wait a
little bit later catch the rest of that
welcome back thank you um entering this
season how did your mindset change as a
person and athlete given all you've gone
through
uh not taking anything for granted you
know life is short
um things can change at the The Stroke
of a match
um
so going into this season just
appreciating everything I mean it you
know the things that I always say you
know appreciate every moment you know
don't take it for granted but it's so
true once something like like this
happens to you you like when people say
that it hits it hits home like it hits
closer to you
um so just taking it all in I mean just
walking in to the arena one day I had a
workout here and uh they had you know
Mercury all around and everything and it
was just such a surreal moment
um no one was in there I was the first
one to walk on the court and it just it
hit me hard you know
um so just looking forward to all those
moments just walking in on the first
home game
um the grind you know the sweat blood
um hopefully not too much blood because
that means injuries so hopefully not too
much of that
um but uh but just taking all that in
you know I missed it like I much I would
have rather been doing a two a days you
know coach don't any ideas
um but I would have I would have rather
been in a two a day dying and you know
uh than to be where I was so just
looking forward to being back to that
foreign
.com you've said
um really throughout your career that
basketball was a sanctuary for you
um has it felt like that coming back you
talked about you wanted to be back where
you were has it felt like a sanctuary
and where do you think you are as a
player at this point and where can you
reach during this season
uh well I mean I always believe in my
ability if we had a game tomorrow I mean
we're gonna we're gonna go we're gonna
go get that dub but um you know being
realistic uh am I aware exactly where I
want to be or no but you know I'm on the
right track to get in there that's for
sure I will say that
um
it's still a sanctuary I mean in the
beginning though you know the first
was I want to say Dave but what was it
baby like two weeks first month
um it was hard
um it's funny because she was literally
filming me in the beginning and um yeah
those videos are really really different
to how they are now you know where I'm
at now you know I feel like I've hit the
corner and uh
just loving it now but at first there
was a there was a point where it was
like wow like Dave do I really want to
do this this fast right now
but uh no it was so worth it so worth it
hi Brittany
these Arizona
Republic your new head coach how have
those conversations been and how was
your support system here in Phoenix I
think the first thing I said was sorry
you know
um she was with Vegas uh that my last
year playing and uh we kind of sent them
home so uh you know uh I kind of made a
joke about that I'm a jokester I use
humor a lot throughout throughout this
whole experience I'm just laughing at
things but
um no it's been great getting to know
her as a person
um
I'm really looking forward to the season
honestly it's it's going to be really
good things here and I'm looking forward
to being coach buyer
hey Brittany uh Robbie Baker with fox10
good to see you and welcome home you
mentioned being back in the arena we've
seen you at the practice facility a few
times with a big smile on your face what
were the emotions like the first time
you got your hands on a basketball again
and getting back on the court
so
um the first time I had a basketball in
my hand uh actually was in uh in San
Antonio
um
it was good it was good uh you know got
some shots up I mean I was in some
Chucks so I was in some low top Chucks
you know just I was outside and you know
like real I thought I was like 16 again
I mean my ankles did not like it uh but
uh it was good I I threw it down just to
see you know I was like
let me just see if I can still throw
this thing down and I did you have to
ask that's a good question for my wife
ask her how it felt getting dunked on
you know did I say that did I say that
out loud
welcome home
point you've become the face of
Americans detained overseas what's that
feel like how are you feeling and how do
you continue
to raise awareness throughout the season
and really you know throughout your
career
uh well I'm
I'm really fortunate to have this
platform that I have and every chance
that I get if it's wearing shirt saying
their names
um
any interview that I have uh and you'll
see the theme throughout the throughout
the season with that that's just
bringing awareness to everybody that
doesn't have the platform and the
followers and you know the exposure to
to everyone like this right now
um
that that is a way that um you know I'm
I'm trying to help out in any way that I
can
um you know we're partnering with uh
we'll bring our families home in Phoenix
Mercury and uh we're gonna be doing a
lot of a lot of good things throughout
the throughout this season uh I know
we're doing the right we're writing
letters to the families
um fans can come and write which I will
suggest everyone doing please because
you don't understand how
how good it felt to get a letter from
your family from just random people that
I've never even met
um
it it just lets you know that you're not
forgotten and it's so easy to feel
forgotten
um to feel like no one's thinking of you
and then when you get a letter from
people that you know and people that you
don't even know uh it it just does
something to you it just gives you like
a spark of life
um to keep holding on keep fighting not
to give in
um so these are things that you know
we're gonna we're gonna do throughout
this season
uh
good morning uh Brittany I'm Bill Rhoden
from ESPN landscape and it's really
great to see you it's good to know the
prayers have been answered uh the
question um you've always represented so
much throughout your entire career about
access and you know being able to do
stuff and I hate to put one more thing
on your plate but there are a number of
states who are aggressively moving to
prevent transgender athletes playing and
I was wondering again I'd hate to put
one more thing on your plate but in
terms of your on your radar where is
that
um you're going to have a tremendous
platform but where is that going to be
on your radar in terms of advocating for
um you know athletes all athletes
transgender to be able to play oh I mean
that that ranks high on the on the list
of things that I'll be fighting for and
speaking up against you know everyone
has everyone deserves the right to play
everyone deserves the right to to come
here sit in these seats and feel safe
and not feel
um like there's a threat or they can't
be who they are or
um like like it's just all eyes on them
uh so
um
I think it's
a crime honestly to
to separate
um someone
for any reason so I definitely will be
speaking up against I suppose that
legislation and those laws that are
trying to be passed for sure
hey Brittany Chris Rim New York Times
two questions for you have you spoken
with Evan the reporter from The Wall
Street Journal or his family at all and
and secondly
when you return did you feel any worry
or guilt or any type of Burden because
of because you came home earlier than
some others who were detained longer
than you
um you know if I could have went in and
got them out or
any of that I mean I of course I would
have
um I think everybody President Biden if
he could just go over there right now
and just grab everybody that that's been
left behind I think he definitely would
I mean of course
um
uh
it's hard it's hard
um you know I come from military family
my dad
um Vietnam 68 69 Marine so you know I
have that mindset you know no man Left
Behind no man no woman no one left
behind
um so you know it hurts it hurts because
no one should be in those conditions
like
hands down no one should be in any of
the conditions that I went through or
they're going through so you know I hope
[Music]
that we everyone continues to bring
awareness and fight to bring home
everyone
um
can you resay the first part of your
question I'm sorry about that
yes so my I haven't spoke directly but I
do know that my team washerman and my
agent they have been in touch with the
family a lot and helping out with just
you know sharing knowledge which is a
big thing you know everybody's speaking
talking sharing what they know it goes a
long way because I mean you're in
foreign territory you're in unknown
Waters so there's a lot you know that we
might know that they didn't know so
there's been a lot of communication
between both teams
[Music]
cap right here hey welcome home
um couple things one um Diane is still
playing what's it like being back and
having another season or two with Diana
head and then also going back to the
bubble
um when you left you got a lot of mental
health
um you've spoken about your mental
help that you got after that how
important was that in dealing with what
you
um had to deal with in Russia uh I mean
that helped a lot you know I've always
promoted you know talking to a counselor
seeking therapy
um any any tool that'll help you you
know get to a good centered place and
I'm still doing that as of right now you
know that'll never change uh I think
it's good to have someone to talk to you
know um so much goes on in this world we
see so much we're exposed to so much on
social media that you know it's just a
lot it's nice to have someone to talk to
um playing with D I mean who wouldn't
want to play with a walking fossil uh
non-player
oh she's gonna kill me
um she's gonna kill me
um no I'm just so glad I was really
worried honestly like I legit I was
worried I thought she was gonna like
retire on me or something while I was
gone or I would miss it and that
honestly was killing me uh knowing
knowing that that you know was a
possibility so I'm really thankful that
you know she's still here she hates it
but you know she's a mentor I look up to
her you know how could you not when you
have the goat you know right next to you
so I'm really thankful to to have her
another year here in Phoenix like like
I'm looking forward to getting out there
on the court
hey BG
uh you kind of alluded to this already
but after the year that you had had how
are you so certain that you wanted to
play in the WNBA this year and how are
you certain that you'd be able to play
so quickly after you came back
oh man I mean I've said it before uh you
know I believe in me I believe in what I
can do I know that I can if I put my
mind to it you know I can I can achieve
any goal
um and you know not trying to sound
big-headed but I just I just really you
know I've bet on me and uh I have all
the resources here to help me get to
that to that point where I can play and
it was it was no question to to be back
in the WNBA back in Phoenix and plan
hey Brittany Elio of goodbye Sports 360
AZ so picking back off of Jeff's
question a little bit what was the
reaction being with the teammates again
and now really feeling physically part
of the team again now that you've been
able to be in it a little bit longer ah
I mean just seeing everybody just being
back uh on my ride back from from San
Antonio here actually uh I was lucky
that uh
um d d was able to come so she was the
first player that I got to see
um you know Vince was there and it was
just really good
um just seeing them it was like a relief
like it was once I've said it before
um it's hard to really realize it's it's
happening you know it's like I'm really
here like this is really my teammates
here uh
so it was it was just liberating it was
it was so great to to be on that
on that plane riding back with her and
then seeing everybody at the at the gym
it was it was crazy oh man it was such a
good feeling
hi Brittany I'm Sydney from USA Today
um what did it feel like first when you
were gone but also when you came home to
have not only the WNBA Community rally
around you but also the lgbtq community
fight for you and support you uh I mean
like I said just just seeing everybody
backing backing me and supporting me
um supporting my family uh you know I
heard about the standing ovation my wife
got when she came to a game you know
like just little things like that
All-Star you know with the league
um just knowing that everyone was going
above and beyond people that I'd never
even met you know
um going to bat for me and supporting me
uh it really shows how much you've kind
of impacted or you've you know touched
so many different people in a different
way
um
so I was just abundant of Joy honestly I
will say
thank you so much Brittany
thank you everybody
[Applause]